But let me come up here. So the purpose I have some comments
in C++ is free to understand again.
What your data structures are doing to memory
because if you want to solve data structures.
Or if you want to write algorithms search algorithms insertion algorithms
deletion algorithms for any particular data structure, especially graph
and binding data structures.
You need to know.
What your program is doing to the memory if you understand
the memory you'll be able to solve those algorithms.
Okay.
But let me give you a quick background about
these two, so.
oh, by the way, I noticed I even made a mistake in
the
C++ this is C++ was created
when in the 70s or 80s, right?
I copy this from this was meant for
JavaScript 1985, by the way.
We also collect this.
right
python
is a programming that is a general what we call a general purpose
program language. What is in what do we mean when we said, you know
purpose it means that you can use it for different purposes.
You all know that python is used for machine learning you can
use it for visualization.
You can write programs for
web servers.
So it is a general purpose program language, but was initially
meant for operating system applications. So applications on
the operating system level.
desktop applications, basically
Now python is what we call strong retired.
That means when you declare a variable, excuse me,
that means when you cannot mix data types
together. So for example, if you have a string and the number you cannot.
Make them together. You cannot concatenate them.
compare that to a Loosely type programmable language or JavaScript
lose the type program language like JavaScript if you have a string and a number and
you try to add it together.
This is a defective operations. So
what JavaScript will do is it will correct it for you.
It will take the number turn it into a string and then put those two strings
together.
And I'll tell you why I'm even discussing this.
Python is that also dynamically typed meaning when
you declare a variable you do not need to declare its
data type.
So for example, if you say if you do something like this.
If you want to create let's say a price.
You can declare the variable and assign it some value.
Whereas in C++ or Java or
any other strongly statically type programmable language,
you would have to also declare the data type.
And even though this is variable in a
statically type program language. You cannot assign it to a different
data type.
So we cannot do something like this, you know, we cannot
say whatever.
Because once you set this to integer, then it has to only work
with integers. Well as in Python, you don't
have to declare the data type.
And you can assign the variable to a different value. This is
what we mean by dynamically typed.
Okay.
Both of them are object-oriented programmable
languages now python is a white space scope.
So if you have not worked python, this might be new to you.
Again, when you watch the recorded tutorial see what I mean by what white
space code.
now if you've only worked with python he
then
there are some things you won't appreciate.
Which C++ helps you appreciate?
Here's why you want to look at those materials and c++? And
here's a comment. I want to make about programming in general.
programming languages that are Dynamic light dynamically
type and especially if they're Loosely typed
they
because they're so flexible.
like the example I showed you they
increase the likelihood of defects appearing in your code.
They increase the likelihood of you producing spaghetti code.
And that just means it will take you longer to solve problems.
It will take you longer to.
You know work with Advanced data structures.
Really the the point I'm
trying to make in general is this and you want to keep this in mind when
you are programming you want to be as strict as possible
the more strict you are.
And the better you understand what your programming is
doing it to the computer the less defective. Your
code will be the less frequent. The number
of defects will occur and
The better you'll be able to work with.
Like I said Advanced data structures.
Okay, so that's really the purpose of why I'm also
going to expose you to some C++.